[Música]
hablamos de salud en france24 y marc
menos mal que ya llegó para sacarnos
todas las dudas con esta nueva variante
del cómic 19 las omicron además un
nombre un poco alarmante pero le
pregunto que hay que saber hay que
alarmarnos o o no hay que ser cautelosos
que debemos hacer más usted está aquí
para eso pues si no podíamos empezar de
otra manera y ser cautelosos siempre
raúl eso es lo más importante para mí
además algo que me parece que es bueno
que hagamos es empezar explicando lo que
no sabemos por qué llevamos repitiendo y
repitiendo que sabemos y al final son
casi que conjeturas no entonces vamos a
empezar explicando las cosas que no
sabemos que precisamente esos motivos
para que tenemos para la prudencia para
empezar no sabemos cómo afectan las
mutaciones a la capacidad de
transmitirse del co bit 19 es cierto que
estas mutaciones están en una parte del
virus de esas coronas que salen no
cuando nos imaginamos el coronavirus que
son precisamente las que se usan para
entrar en las células contagiarlas y
replicarse entonces podemos conjeturar
que puede ser que sea más transmisible
pero en realidad no lo sabemos
una cosa que hemos repetido mucho es que
los casos en sudáfrica se han triplicado
que han aumentado mucho pero en realidad
no sabemos si eso se debe a que hay más
testigos precisamente por la alarma
generada por omicron o si efectivamente
es que esta variante está contagiando
más en el país otra cosa que no sabemos
es qué tan grave es la enfermedad que
provoca no sabemos si realmente va a ser
un kobe 19 más grave o no por ahora
todos los casos que sean reportados son
o bien asintomáticos o con síntomas
leves parecidos como en cogollos
normales atrás variantes como un cover
normal pero tampoco podemos asegurar
nada al respecto de eso y por último no
sabemos cómo afectan las vacunas como
enfrentarán estos fármacos a un micro no
se está experimentando ya se está
empezando a saber y también pues como
siempre podemos hacer algunas conjeturas
escuchemos las recordando que por ahora
son solo eso
lo que sabemos basándonos en las
mutaciones que existen en esta variante
en particular y que podemos extrapolar
por qué varias mutaciones se superponen
con variantes previas es que confieren
algún nivel de escape a los anticuerpos
con su asamblea de los genes
berzins pero las vacunas no sólo
protegen con anticuerpos de hecho lo
hemos visto contra otras variantes las
vacunas protegen bien contra la
enfermedad y la hospitalización
playstation es por eso no hay
preocupaciones reales en este momento es
points investigar marx y es que no sólo
con esta variante omicron sino que
también el hobbit 19 pues es diferente
en cada organismo y pues a todo el mundo
le dará diferente de acuerdo a cómo el
organismo procese este virus pero ahora
vamos a hablar de las farmacéuticas que
se han expresado la preocupación por esa
nueva variante y por ahí hay una
declaración un poco preocupante para
nosotros un poco como alarmista también
normal totalmente de eso precisamente
quería hablar de raúl porque es que ya
todas las farmacéuticas han apresurado a
decir que están trabajando en una nueva
vacuna o una las modificaciones de la
vacuna existente para enfrentar la
variante del cobe 19 omicron pero no
todavía ni siquiera sabemos si es
necesario y de hecho esa referencia que
tú estabas diciendo es del siguió el
director ejecutivo de moderna estefan
stefan bands el perdón que dijo que lo
más probable es que su vacuna no
funcione o funcione peor contra omicron
y todo esto lo dijo sin ni siquiera
tener datos sobre cómo puede enfrentarse
o cómo puede afectar la vacuna a la
variante por lo tanto son unas
declaraciones desde nuestro punto de
vista un tanto irresponsables además no
hace falta sólo que las farmacéuticas
modifiquen sus vacunas sino que también
los lentos reguladores las aprueben y
las revisen y precisamente sobre eso se
pronunció la agencia europea del
medicamento veamos lo que dijeron
podríamos estar en la posición de
necesitar cambiar las vacunas que
existen podríamos estar en la posición
de aprobarlas entre tres y cuatro meses
desde los inicios de los cambios
pero la primera decisión que debemos
tomar es saber si eso es necesario
streep otra cosa que me parece bien
interesante raúl es recordar que hay
otras enfermedades y otras vacunas que
también necesitan modificarse por
mutaciones en el virus un ejemplo es la
de la gripe las vacunas se modifican
casi que anualmente sin necesidad
tampoco de pasar por los entes
reguladores así que no sería la primera
vez que nos encontramos en una situación
así y no va a ser tan difícil como es lo
normal además marc que estas vacunas
realmente cambien mediante cambio un
virus cualquiera ahora le pregunto como
explicamos que esta variante haya
sufrido en sudáfrica y dejemos por favor
también a un lado le pedimos la
estigmatización de donde salen estas
variantes claro de hecho además no es
casual y los países del norte global no
dejan de ser algo responsables de que
esta variante haya surgido en el
continente africano práctica casualmente
en botsuana y en sudáfrica no no nos
vamos tampoco a cansar de repetir que
las desigualdades en la repartición de
las vacunas afectan estas cosas la
vacuna evita la transmisión la
transmisión evita las mutaciones
recordemos la media de población
vacunada en el mundo es del 42 95 por
ciento todas las regiones del mundo
están por encima de esa media e incluso
algunas están por encima del 50% pero
áfrica la sigue a una distancia abismal
raúl sólo el 7,15 por ciento de la
población en el continente africano está
vacunada y como decíamos parte de esta
responsabilidad también la tienen los
países ricos los países con recursos
como los del norte global hagamos una
comparación de cifras por ejemplo en
europa se han administrado más de 63
millones de dosis de refuerzo únicamente
de refuerzo mientras que en áfrica y una
adecuada 4 trabajadores sanitarios que
sólo está vacunado no falta muchísima
gente por vacunar con todas esas dosis
de refuerzo asumiendo que son vacunas de
2 dosis se podrían haber vacunado hasta
6 veces todos los trabajadores
sanitarios del continente africano es
decir que hay una diferencia abrumadora
al final entre cómo se están repartiendo
esas vacunas cómo se están priorizando y
pues eso tiene consecuencias muy graves
de hecho china como anunciamos también
en los noticieros prometió mil millones
de vacunas ya para el continente
africano
indian no especificó una cifra pero
también dijo que va a aumentar sus
donaciones y a pesar de que esas son
relativas buenas noticias de cooperación
internacional también no dejan de
esconder un problema de fondo y es que
áfrica es totalmente dependiente en
materia sanitaria de las donaciones de
la buena voluntad y eso también la deja
a merced de cosas como esa diplomacia de
la salud en la que a veces el interés de
dar las vacunas no nace solo pues de las
buenas intenciones de que todo el mundo
esté vacunado sino también de pues de
intereses de otras potencias de influir
en la región marc pues gracias por
hacernos entender un poco de esta nueva
variante omicron vamos ahora con nuestro
segundo tema al día